Macaroni and cheese scented air fresheners
and bacon and egg earrings.
It's episode 19 of LÜT.
This clock tells the correct time, except
it runs backwards.
And Thailand Unique will sell you a bottle
of whiskey with a cobra in it, delicious chocolate
covered silkworms, a can of BBQ scorpions
or a nice bag of edible pregnant crickets.
If the thought of eating bugs leaves you with
cold feet, make them colder with this snowball
shooting crossbow and then warm them back
up with these USB powered heated slippers.
Or, show your team spirit with Vat19's giant
puffy NFL sneaker slippers while feeding your
baby with an Enterprise spoon that can drip
food all over a flashing LED tricky bib.
Your bib, of course, should be formal.
Buy a baby rattle that makes your baby look
buff and when they get older don't give them
army men, give them breakdance men.
Or treat yourself to a cute cuddly stuffed
animal cupcake, a pistol with a cowboy hat,
a slice of pizza, a stack of pancakes or,
my favourite, the zebra rabbit with a moustache.
Get your lady a pair of hand-painted Star
Wars shoes or these eye shadows from GeekChic
cosmetics, based on the colours of the Mushroom
Kingdom.
Oh, and don't forget this shade of lipstick,
it's called Hipster Ariel.
Be even hipper with a levitating lamp that
looks like it's been slashed by a light sabre.
And here's a wire frame you can use to make
any chair suggest the idea of a throne.
Ferrofluids are colloids containing magnetic
material, so they respond to magnetic fields
and their own cohesion and surface tension.
You can buy a whole play kit or a litter of
the stuff.
Now, just don't drink it.
Instead, drink some civet coffee.
This coffee is produced by having civets run
around eating the very best beans they find.
These guys swallow it, digest it and enzymes
in their intestine change the beans, which
they poop out completely whole.
So farmers collect the poop, wash it off,
roast the beans and produce for you the best,
smoothest and most expensive coffee on earth.
Full disclosure - I bought some of this last
year for my dad on Father's Day and it was
delicious.
I'm gonna shout out ScienceBob.
Now, you Leanbackers know him, his site store
is cool.
He's got smoke shooting guns and smoke guans,
owl pallets that you can dissect to get rat
bones out of.
Science for the win.
And as always,
thanks for watching.